thank you so much for calling vip zappos
zappos.com one of fortune magazine's top
10 best companies to work for i'll be
happy to look into that for you and who
am i speaking with today
the multi-million dollar company based
in henderson
is the brainchild of entrepreneur tony
shea
i guess i wouldn't say ambitious more
probably just the
type of person that gets bored easily
shea says his passion for business
didn't start with selling shoes but
earthworms
bought a bunch of them and thought i
could grow them and produce more worms
but
that didn't quite work out they all
escaped when the worm business
didn't hit pay dirt he moved on there's
the lemonade stand
there's this small mail order
button business where i would make the
buttons that people pin on
after graduating from harvard shea and
his roommate created
linkexchange.com we grew that to about
100 or so people and then ended up
selling the company to
microsoft two and a half years later for
a whopping
265 million dollars eventually using
that money to invest in a small.com
that sold shoes
no not at all i i mean i'm still not
today
zappos became so popular amazon.com
bought it for 1.2 billion making shea
even richer he always believes
regardless of who he meets or what they
do
that there's something that he can learn
from them shea's longtime
friend and cfo fred mosler says tony
never wanted the big corner office so
today
he has a cubicle tony's very very humble
and how he approaches his life he's
achieved a lot
and sums it all in a book he titled
delivering happiness
it's really about toughing through the
hard moments
shea says the secret to his success can
be achieved
in three words never give up
persistence and resilience play a big
role
and i think a lot of people actually do
give up
too early that ambitious kid who started
with worms
never gave up and that's his key to
delivering
happiness
you